peter i was on 937 the fan yesterday
afternoon drive with andrew phillipone
and
and it was suggested this wasn't my idea
but i liked it enough to file it away
think about it maybe write about it at
pft
promote mike muncheck to head coach of
the pittsburgh steelers and trade mike
tomlin to someone else and i'd never
thought about it from the standpoint of
the team that has the head coach under
contract affirmatively trading him it
usually happens when someone else wants
him
i kind of blew my mind but you know what
ben roethlisberger has come out
aggressively in favor of doing
everything possible to keep mike munchak
he says write letters to art rooney do
whatever you can to keep mike munchek
the offensive line has been great with
him around wouldn't that be something if
the steelers would try something like
that i don't think they will but it was
enough of an idea to get me to say wow
you know what that's kind of a
fascinating concept and it would solve
some of their problems right now if they
think muncheck really is the guy
it's a really interesting thing
obviously i never thought of that uh
until you mention it mike
i i just look at the pittsburgh steelers
three coaches in 50 seasons we're coming
up on in three weeks
on the 50-year anniversary of the hiring
of chuck noll by the pittsburgh steelers
they take pride in continuity in
longevity and they're invested in mike
tomlin as the leader of their team i
believe
that mike tomlin has some business to do
to both reclaim the locker room and
either to fix or to abandon ship on
antonio brown
but i would be very surprised i don't i
i'd really have to think about that one
about whether that's the best idea for
the team or not
but i just think it has 0.0 percent
chance of happening it's a very blue
tarsky uh possibility i i think that the
firing of joey porter last week was kind
of a shot across the bow at tommen
because they were close and i never
think that any of these decisions are
made by the head coach in pittsburgh i
always feel like it's made one or two
levels higher than the head coach but
you know i i i understand that they've
had three coaches in 50 years it's
become part of their identity but i
think that can be dangerous right i
think that continuing to cling to tomlin
just because you like to say hey we've
only had three coaches since 1969. is
that really in the best interest of the
team at a certain point it's not now
look i'm not saying you fire him just to
say hey we're breaking from tradition
but i don't think you cling to the
tradition just for the sake of the
tradition you do what's right for the
team and and only they know what's going
on behind closed doors what we've seen
and what we've heard in recent weeks
isn't pretty and it speaks to some
serious issues that they need to address
however they address them peter
you know it's interesting i just
recorded a podcast uh conversation with
a dd king kabwala of nfl network who has
been around the steelers since 2012 and
especially this year an awful lot he's
got good sources in the building
and um she she believes that there's
some significant problems uh beyond just
antonio brown uh in that building and on
that team
um it's a it'll be an inter any steeler
fan i'm not promoting my podcast
necessarily but i just think we got into
some really deep issues about some of
the things that are wrong with that team
on the peter king podcast which will be
up tomorrow
but i also but you're not promoting this
mike
no not at all i would never do that i
never promote something that
selfishly of mine
but but mike i think the one thing right
now
that the steelers have to look at i mean
isn't it interesting that ben
roethlisberger has been the mvp of this
team not since 2009 in this player
voting i mean what does that tell you
it's i mean every year he's one of the
best quarterbacks in the league and the
quarterback is always the mvp but the
steelers never vote him the mvp of this
team
yeah it's like it's like why did juju
smith schuster win it over antonio brown
this year isn't that a little bit of a
sign and so
there are things roiling beneath the
service that in my opinion mike tomlin
has got to get a hold of and when he
meets his team again assuming he stays
coach he meets his team again in april
i'm just telling you that has to be job
one on the mike tomlin list get they
gotta do it before april they gotta do
it before april peter they gotta get
antonio brown ben roethlisberger mike
tomlin in a room and figure this out
because my understanding is this really
is a ben versus antonio issue no matter
how much ben tries to publicly deny it
ben doesn't like antonio at this point
he thinks he's entitled and that was the
root of what happened a couple of weeks
ago and and they've got to figure it out
because march 17 two and a half million
dollars is due to be paid to antonio
brown and if the steelers are going to
trade and they need to do it before then
so they have to figure this out and and
i agree with you there are issues and
it's amazing they've been as successful
as they've been despite these issues but
i think these issues have held them back
from being as successful as they could
be
no question about it and i think what i
suggested in my column this week mike
football morning in america
wait until all the dust settles wait
four five six weeks
someday in february mike tomlin's gotta
go have lunch with antonio brown at a
place where nobody knows who they are
and they just have to have this
conversation are you in are you out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports